today's topic he says he was sitting on
his porch around 2:00 a.m. Saturday when
he saw his neighbors doors open and I
noticed all the lights were on it was
bright and I didn't hear anything didn't
see anything and I thought best to go
please
let's start when the video starts 231
a.m. and 42 seconds the body camera
video shows the officer checking the
front door of the house you see the
screen door closed but the front door is
open from there the officer walks to the
right to the east side of the house you
can see the white car parked under the
carport the officer walks up to the side
door that screen door there is also
closed but the main door again is open
so the officer can see into the house
when the officer gets to the back of the
house there's a blue car parked in front
of the garage he turns on his flashlight
and checks the gate to the back yard
that's at 2:32 a.m. and 24 seconds it's
been 42 seconds since he checked the
front door and he has not identified
himself as a police officer at 2:32 a.m.
and 48 seconds
the officer opens the gate and walks
into the back yard you see the
air-conditioning unit at the back of the
house they're just eight seconds later
you see the officer walked to the window
at the back of the house Tatyana
Jefferson is standing on the other side
of that window you hear the officer Yelp
put your hands up let me see your hands
which adds up from ads he immediately
fires the single shot through the window
killing a Tatyana hmm I I don't want to
spend too much time speaking on the
particulars of the case because I feel
like this shooting is indefensible first
let's talk about the neighbor I'm
devastated because people say well James
it's not your fault you're not jump off
but I made a call
neighbor was concerned for his neighbor
Tatiana and seeing the door open decided
to make a non-emergency call police came
and killed her
and this neighbor's response to what
happened is that he felt too guilty it
would be like you seeing smoke coming
out of a house you call the fire
department they set the house on fire
and you blame yourself do you understand
in his head what he's internalize is
that I called killers on my neighbor and
now he has to live with that trauma his
entire life that's what it is though and
then think about the eight-year-old
nephew who was playing video games like
Tatiana when that shooting happened she
was in her living room heard noises went
to the window to check it out because
she cared for her nephew now imagine was
going through that nephew's mind he sees
her his aunt go up to the window Hugh
hears a noise he hears a put your head
boom so now his ears are ringing he's
confused
two strangers white man he's never seen
his life in full gear come running to
the house they start checking the
perimeter and make sure it's safe they
clear the gun then he notices his aunt
is on the floor motionless he doesn't
know how to respond cuz he's choked up
police officers come back they start to
admit her CPR he calls his aunt's name
she doesn't respond and then at some
point the breath keep going in but no
breath comes out and it's understood
that she's dead he might say her name a
few more times but he doesn't know
ambulances Russian families coming in
kids still it was really confused and
incomplete shocked now you got media
rolling in all the neighbors are angry
hundreds of police officers are on the
scene he has to leave his own home
and so now he's gonna go through a media
circus for a couple of weeks his whole
family's distraught crying reeling from
this and then probably three or four
weeks from now he's gonna go back to
school my teacher is gonna come up and
say I what's happened to you is really
hard if you ever feel like you need to
talk come talk to me and then he's gonna
go into class some kids are gonna know
what happening or looking and weird
others are gonna be oblivious classes
are gonna start things are gonna move
forward and eventually he's gonna have
to learn to just swallow all the images
that he had to see as an eight-year-old
and start moving on and that trauma that
he has is never going to really be
addressed and he's gonna carry that with
him for the rest of his life any time he
hears a loud noise those flashback my
Cub you don't know how trauma and huge
experiences that you deal with that as a
kid affect you later on in life and what
she recognizes that cycle of violence
that cycle of trauma is so common our
neighborhoods there's so many young
black people growing up in that even if
it's not them it's their neighbors it's
their siblings and you know I'm just
unpacking some of the traumatic
experience that I had my kid how my
childhood and how it affects me as an
idol imagine for them you know that's
crazy
and it's a it's a scary place to raise
your childhood that's funny because I
remember when I was growing up we were
driving around the neighborhood going
back home it was a rule in the car that
it was illegal to open the lights inside
the car mm-hmm my parents said that a
few times no he can't do that
you're not allowed but it's really just
because they didn't want like now I get
it they didn't want to attract attention
mmm
they didn't want to attract attention to
them being the only black people in that
neighborhood they don't want to attract
attention cops or whatever
told me if there was a problem look for
an adult don't bother the cops later on
in life I sat down and understood what
they were trying to say they were trying
to have to talk with me without shaman
sizing me because my surrounding was
white and not me thinking and not me
thinking bad of white people or white
society but a demon that they feeling
with the police I had to be very careful
and I'm gonna need everybody to stop
talking about a tatianna and how much of
a good person she is because when you
guys start to look towards our good
qualities to make this shooting even
more indefensible
what ends up happening is that you
devalue the lives of people who may have
been a strain their personal life a
little bit and you justify their murder
so you you look at I thought she had a
perfect cleaning clean record there's no
reason should her but because Eric
Gardner was selling loose cigarettes is
somehow more justifies us murder we have
this narrative that we are starting to
play into even as black people where we
like we feel the need to justify
someone's life based off of their record
listen I've not always been a good
person in my younger years I was a
troublemaker now today with my military
service with my place in society and how
I'm involved in community people would
say I'm an upstanding citizen but if I
get into shooting at 18 and people
justify that because I was a little bit
of a [ __ ] then then I never get to
be the better human being I have today
and when you kill someone at any point
regardless of their criminal record you
rob them of their ability to become a
rehabilitated human being so I don't
want to hear nobody tell me about how
much of a good human what I know if
somebody was shot in their own home for
another for nothing and that's all I
need to know everything else is
irrelevant to this discussion people
always want to talk on emotional
heartstrings get that [ __ ] out of here I
want something that's simple and just
what are the facts I don't need to I
don't care that she was a churchgoer I
don't care that she was a mother of
twenty kids I don't care if it's Mother
Teresa or the [ __ ] kid who stole from
a granny last can
shoot them in their house for nothing so
I don't want to see no hugging from
judges no Bibles no awkward forgiveness
ceremonies I don't want to hear about a
police department releasing images of a
gun that had nothing to do with the
shooting when it was sitting on the
dresser don't release that image and
then afterwards say the the the police
officer was in the wrong if he's in the
wrong why did you release that image to
fit a certain narrative whenever these
shootings happened especially around
black people you recognize that the
specific type of photos so even the
media plays into that narrative though
even if this man goes to jail for life
and nothing's gonna change no because as
a society you know and this is all over
the world you go anywher blackness is
viewed as lesser than disposable ugly a
threat go to India their caste system
you'll see based off darkness and not
very positive when I go to Africa skin
bleaching billion-dollar industry the
darker you are the worse you are crying
the same thing go anywhere around the
world and darkness is not well viewed
and until we change our perception of
dark people of darker skin our internal
bias that judge that that affects our
split-second decisions will always
remain because if you think about this
incident this was a split-second
decision this was a white police officer
who entered a black neighborhood and he
was already on guard okay she saw a
black woman in her home saw a gun on the
dresser immediately went to the highest
form of threat you think this happened
in white neighborhoods of course not
because of that bias that officer didn't
have the time to rope you have holes
whose shooter is getting capture to life
the discussion on blackness is I think
why so many black people all over the
world react when a shooting happens in
America is because we understand that
feeling of being feared of being seen as
a danger as being seen as squash a ball
just on the basis of our skin and that's
pervasive everywhere everywhere and so
when we see what's happening in America
it's a microcosm of what's happening all
over the world and that's why everyone
can't help but react so I
have no easy solutions for this I don't
know where this discussion needs to go
but I do know there's things that we
haven't discussed so I just want to
leave that out there there's anything
you want ad hoc you laid it to this feel
like it man you got you got your black
shooting vaccine
[Music]